quittons pas la région de fontainebleau
pour poursuivre notre visite des lieux
touristiques et agréables de la région
que guérini à yves de wulf nous font
découvrir à côté du château de
fontainebleau des parcours de visite
totalement inédit ils sont proposés au
groupe
il suffit juste d'en faire la demande et
de réserver promenade
en pénétrant dans ces lieux peu connus
c'est comme si vous peinez trier plus
connu dans un vieux grenouille famille
plein de trésors enfermés dans des
malles d'osier avec des odeurs des
poussières les résonances lointaine et
lumière oubli est quelque part la
mémoire la mémoire qui fait le reste
toute personne qui est passé par l'école
primaire connaît ses grands personnages
et on les retrouve et fier dans leurs
habitudes leurs dans leur vie familiale
napoléon iii était bâtie vers
fontainebleau louis 15 s'est marié
fontainebleau
philippe iv le bel est mort à
fontainebleau on trouve des épisodes
heureux ou malheureux de toute
l'histoire de france au château le
charme du château réside dans la
diversité des styles qui partent du
moyen-âge passe en france va prôner la
renaissance pour aboutir à des ensembles
de faux positifs menu il faut des blues
possèdent une autre solution
napoléon iii et avant de me les rats de
france différents s'ouvre venait ici
dans une grande famille
l'état finalement dans sa présentation
la plus solennelle se trouvait au louvre
tuileries à versailles selon les époques
ici fêtait la vieille maison familiale
l'avons venait passer des comptes
vacances là où on venait aussi de
chasser car la chasse de fontainebleau
étaient abondants à une échelle
différente
cet état d'esprit régnant encore dans
l'enceinte car si la réputation
internationale assure sans peine
l'affluence des visiteurs étrangers
les responsables du domaine eux ont mis
en place une politique attractive de
tarifs de pédagogie qui se tourne
franchement vers la région les jeunes
les écoles et les centres aérés avec le
passé pour la demie une ambition secrète
utiliser les richesses à portée de la
main
on espère bien transformer ce théâtre
gérant conservatoire s'agissant des
métiers du théâtre puisque toute la
mécanique notamment est encore en place
nous sommes devant l'entrée principale
la course des as lieu endroit où
l'empereur napoléon 1er fils d'adieu à
sa garde le 20 avril 1814
avant de partir en exil alipay attention
connu